Speaker 1: And finally today, again, folks, I'm
so sorry we are running out of time, but I do have
one more thing I want to talk about here, and that
is South Dakota Governor Kristi Noem. Kristi Noem,
an ethics board this week in South Dakota.
Said that it's likely, likely they said
that she engaged in misconduct with regard to
her daughter's real estate appraiser's license.
This is a weird, weird.
Speaker 2: Story.
Speaker 1: Because it also involves a Republican
attorney general who had to resign in.
Speaker 2: Disgrace after he ran over somebody.
Speaker 1: But this Republican attorney
general at one point was hot on Nome's trail
working on this case, you know, and until he
pretty much killed somebody and had to leave
office. It's not funny that somebody died.
Speaker 2: It's just funny that these
Republicans in South Dakota are so screwed up.
Speaker 1: But anyway, what had happened?
Was that Christy Nome's daughter a
couple of years ago? Was that Cassidy.
Speaker 2: Peters?
Speaker 1:
Wanted to become a real estate appraiser, but
you get to have a license in South Dakota to do
that. So she applies. She takes the tests, all
of this, and they look at it and they say, no,
you can't have your real estate appraisers
license. But Mommy was the governor. So
what Kristi Noem did was she called
a meeting and she called a meeting
with the state employee who ran the
agency that gives those licenses,
the woman's direct supervisor and the state labor
secretary. And for some reason, even though she's
not a part of the government, Kassidy Peters,
Noem's daughter, was also involved in that meeting
for months after that meeting. Magically, Kristi
Noem daughter gets that real estate license or
real estate appraiser's license. And then they
also fired the individual who had originally.
Speaker 2: Denied her the license.
Speaker 1: We do not know. I mean,
we don't know for certain what happened in that
meeting. We obviously see the outcomes. The person
who denied the license loses her job. They then
pay her $200,000 to not file a discrimination
suit against them. And Kassidy Peters gets her.
Speaker 2: Real estate appraiser's license.
Speaker 1: Everybody goes home happy,
right? And so this ethics board
in South Dakota says, we think, you know,
it's likely that she engaged in misconduct.
Speaker 2: Likely.
Speaker 1: The issue
is not over. But unfortunately, we are out of
time. But I think I got all that we know so far.
But anyway, thank you so much for tuning in. We
got a great bonus show coming up for everybody,
including Rick Scott leaving the country,
right as Republicans want answers.
Speaker 2: About where all their money went.
Speaker 1: I am Farron Cousins. I've been in
for David Pakman. You can find me at
YouTube.com. Slash the ring of fire
youtube dot com slash fair and balanced.
Twitter, Facebook, Instagram at fair and
balanced. This is the David Pakman show.
Speaker 2: Thanks for watching.